(bar patrons chatting)
Hey, do you have wifi here?
Drrr, obviously we
have fricking wifi here.
What is this, Bob Dole's
personal office? (grunts)
Go fricking serve some
drinks, I got this IRL,
and IRL being you. (grunts)
My name is Mark, I'm
pretty the bar's web guru
slash IT guy and I just
swapped in for a new modem.
I have a very specific
set of skills.
(grunts)
Liam Neeson, like, from, like,
he was also Qui-Gon Jinn.
Anyway, this fricking dong long,
he thought that
we could be using
an 802.11a, as though he's
never heard of a .11n.
(grunts)
Hey, hey, please
don't drink the swill.
Well, listen, I just
need the code to the wifi.
Quit rushing me.
Honestly, what is
this, Temple Run?
So, basically, I
took it upon myself
to upgrade the wifi
name to MV2291234589,
and it's easy to remember
'cause it's my initials
followed by my social.
But that's the
beginning of it all, OK?
Because only a fricking nube
would leave a wifi
public like this, OK?
What am I, fricking
Bernie Sanders
giving out free college
to everybody? (grunts)
Look, I'm waiting on an
important email from my boss.
Then you're gonna want
to know the password
and so obviously I wanted
a very comprehensive
and sophisticated password,
but this muscle meat boy,
he thinks that we
should have a very
easy to know password,
so I made the password
If Voldemort was
so frickin' smart
how come he didn't
have a Time Turner,
also what the frick Mark Veejen
is the smartest
wizard of all time.
All lower case, with
the vowels replaced
by the peach emoji.
OK, I'm signed on, but
the wifi seems super weak.
Uh, yeah, I'm mining
crypto in the back
so that checks out.
Barkeep, another flagon of ale.